missouri governor mike parson  had said he would pardon them  and now he has mark mccloskey pleaded  guilty to misdemeanor 4th degree assault  and paid a 750 fine patricia mccloskey  pleaded guilty to misdemeanor harassment  she was fined two thousand dollars  um and now they have been pardoned it's  not as though even what they were what  they pleaded guilty to was going to  really affect them uh but now they've  been pardoned and the pardon is really  just a political thing and the most  frustrating thing to me pat about this  is that there are so many people who  deserve to be pardoned whose stories  never get the light of day because  they're just not no no there's no  notoriety in the way that this had with  it this had notoriety and now  all of the attention led to them being  pardoned as these heroes and for me it's  not just about they don't deserve to be  pardoned it's so many people and their  stories will never even make it to the  governor